hi reject nation I'm Greg I'm John I'm
Olivia yes that's your name
we're gonna watch episode three of
stranger things three excited to get
into it all right if you've been
watching from the beginning you've heard
me say all the stuff before your choice
whether or not you want to sit through
this part or skip on ahead
so YouTube only allows for ten minute
reaction highlights to be included
maximum amount so our stream along for
stranger things are all gonna be over at
our patreon page did want to mention to
hit that subscribe button click that
notification bell you'll want to get
notified when our next reaction is up
we're uploading these one day at a time
please do hit that notification Bell
over at our patreon though we do stream
along for several shows as well that
includes Gotham hunting Hillhouse Cobra
Kai season two several shows we do cover
actually have stream alongs and reaction
highlights included those are my hero
academia Fullmetal Alchemist Brotherhood
one punch man attack on titan and
supernatural in the reaction highlights
for this show are being edited by Eric
over at nerve chronic thank you so much
for cutting that up he's done work for
people like aqus on Iman SMO that's who
say her name
Yvonne Snow and the movie trivia Schmo
down he has his own podcast forever
podcasts are found including on YouTube
as well so please give him a follow he's
a really good friend of ours anything
else I forgot to mention hit that like
button because it really helps these
videos right and if this video
eventually gets blocked that's why you
gotta hit that notification about this
never know which one of these adversary
acts is gonna get blocked it just
happens sometimes
[Music]
Oh No Oh is some great writing I know
it's done see it
[Music]
haha oh my goodness so know how to cut
to their title sequence
[Music]
tonight
I love look together I love the Bevin
together I love the sound design as it
stands up - I think this is big book
mysterious case of missing fertilizer I
hate men
hazard most of Hawkins like experience
be like this might not be ridiculous
[Laughter]
[Music]
maybe they are
I'll put our friends who played dozens
of trying to dress like the lab I'll use
my torso set fire to the chambers
sacrificing ourselves killing did you
choose the same mechanism we all notice
here as the memories
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
where was that to survive growing up and
I like and girls it's gay yeah sure
which one that way
[Music]
[Music]
oh my god
[Music]
[Music]
okay fine only the car do you buy your
export earning at Russian target a
cluttered stereotyping
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
tripped up down underneath dad dad Brent
yeah under everyday upside doc links
silver cat blinks in the silver cap I
solved it what they need to find a
silver cat
[Music]
oh the ball was a conspiracy I don't
think it's what I thought it was losing
your money seems a lot better kept
together than usual to be honest is
important to me did you feel safe on
your family I want you to feel like this
is so beautiful
kids mom yeah
of course she wants to move on then
right it makes sense
factor shows it would you get that
straight give people the movie but
people who care right
[Music]
oh god is it Bob five extra arms that
hopperoo look like little Joyce gets
here I'll copy
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what
Oh
[Music]
God will I just had the office
my keys for
[Music]
we've been here before we've danced this
dance but it's getting more used to be
[Music]
oh poor old lady
hold it in hands
Oh sister man he keeps getting in like
branded kidneys hoppers this is gonna
kill him this
I can't wait oh so much braking there's
something wrong okay okay
why would you be okay where is she
oh [ __ ] you saw me like a Clark berries
[Music]
Oh dirty twisted my bridesmaid Maxine
and I'm sorry I did not quite catch your
name oh now Heather wasn't feeling so
hot today so we thought we'd take the
day off to nurseries good
Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
everyone is connected to it
oh dude the parents are gonna get
[ __ ] killed our parents drugged them
[Music]
Wow whoa
[Music]
[Music]
oh whoa boy ah it's great it was amazing
right good all right well that was
amazing that was great I love the way
the writing is being done this season
like we were talking about with Episode
two like they were throwing you really
into their personal lives first and then
letting the supernatural stuff really
come later and it's all flowing into it
so organically it's the personal life
conflicts that are leading them into the
supernatural stuff in such an organic
way like right from the beginning when
xi decides to playing spin the bottle
and look into Billy's life that happened
in such a fluid motion that I wasn't
thinking it's gonna lead to something
else I was like oh this is actually
pretty cool they're using your powers
for some my personal life stuff that I'm
sure like if a teenager had this ability
they'd probably do it if they're gonna
situated I like that touch to it
and you're seeing like these multiple
adventures where all these characters
are divided doing separate things and I
just can't wait to see how it all comes
together eventually yeah man I feel like
part of the magic of this show has been
like just going how would people
actually respond to these various
situations and stuff and there are a lot
of nuances that get brought up in this
episode too like I loved all the stuff
between hopper and Joyce in this episode
and how kind of strained and odd their
relationship has become I feel like some
of the nancy stuff gets a little on the
nose with just like how cartoonishly
dickish the people at the office are but
like the whole intrigue of her and
sidekick Jonathan going yeah check out
this like weird rat thing and going back
to the old woman's house like I don't
know yeah it seems like they've really
found a whole bunch of smart ways of
creating a new variety with the
characters creating new drama but like I
actually felt for wil when he started
breaking down Castle buyers and just
like the way in which they've all just
grown apart and like he missed so much
time and his friends have just grown
past him it really makes this really
nice dramatic nugget of loneliness for
him that just yet it seems like they
have a great grip on making their cool
stuff really cool and then their
character stuff really effective I
enjoyed the different theme
this season has brought so far I feel
like you have the supernatural themes
you have the family themes and even with
Billy being possessed really and like
they're tethered portions of themselves
it brings in like this thriller serial
killer vibe like that whole last scene
was incredible and it was almost like it
reminded me of the invitation and
segment invitation at us yeah it was
fantastic and I really like those
different themes throughout the season
favorite episode so I'm not really
connecting with Nancy's storylines so
much because I do think it's very
cartoonish and over-the-top and I'm like
okay I get it like oh yes I understand
that's how women retreat but it's just
so you know last kill the coffee and do
what you hired to do you mean something
weird could be going on in Hawkins lady
stupid it's just so over the top so this
one portion of it that I'm not really
connecting with but luckily if they're
not shown that much okay well then the
Nancy character I like that they made
her really grow into an adult and at
least she's trying to be as much of an
edit oh my gosh
Watson Wow well she's trying to be an
adult as much as possible I'm not a fan
of the only three episodes never there's
only 18 episodes it's like what they've
done with Jonathan is really taken just
this we said in the last episode but in
this one is entombed he's really not
here to do anything else we go I got a
question for okay I'll do it every yeah
I'm here to help you process the debate
of whatever your character's about to go
do
yeah and the thing is that's the one
bummer for me I think so far this season
that's standing out because I don't
think they need to make that sorry so
ham-fisted and I think it's a good idea
anyway to have them further exploring
the journalism angle so yeah I hope they
find a way to balance it out and
coalesce it into the rest of the show
cuz it does seem like the one
undercooked piece right now yeah I mean
I've honestly since last season I'm
never really quite connected with Nancy
or Jonathan so I'm not exactly bummed by
my disconnect that I've been
experiencing with them but you probably
said it best the whole undercooked
element it's like it's not a
disappointing thing to me because I did
really had expectations for not that I
dislike them it's just I've never really
been drawn to them yeah but there's
still so many things here that are
amazing I love the dynamic chemistry has
been forming between Max and 11:00 yeah
the way they've this son of a let their
characters grow and be really explore
the show by letting different characters
hang out with one another here I mean
they really capitalize on the Dustin and
Steve situation with their chemistry
because whenever they're on-screen
together it's easily the funniest the
shows it's so is such a joy like they're
my favorite characters because of it
yeah like there might not be the most
in-depth characters but they're my
favorite because because they were done
there together I'm having such a great
time one weirdly they're the easiest to
root for because they're the most sort
of everyman underdone yeah now they've
both just kind of had to rise to the
occasion
well they don't really have anything
that extraordinary to go on other than
just grit the Robin character is really
cool this specific episode is easily the
most intense out of the three we've seen
so far but you know certain things has
earned that's sort of like good faith of
you just know like that the first couple
episodes are usually the set up but that
you know it's gonna get going this
episode is like oh my god its transition
into the intensity of all the situations
without whoa it's transitioned into the
intensity of the situation that's like
you pull back the curtain to the
intensity without it being like
in-your-face at oh no don't worry it's
gonna come it's a
to happen right now it didn't in an
unexpected way it's cool to be three
seasons in and still feel like the
unexpected turns are truly unexpected
like the way they were just colliding
with all the storylines towards the end
where they're looking at the Russians
are actually here in the fact that they
figured it out but you don't know what
the hell they're doing like that's scary
they go to the lab and some guy jumps
them who we've seen a couple of times
not want to know who that character is
now everything with like Billy the
Heather girl being missing but then you
know eleven really knows something which
is not what the gang and then will being
apart but he's still connected like all
these pieces coming together such
dramatic heft that I just love so yeah
this is just a great episode it ends in
such like a oh my god you know yeah I
thought binging this might be a little
bit of a chore but you know what it's
[ __ ] breezy it's awesome nowadays
they've mathematically engineer them to
were like I gotta watch yeah well they
design like the first couple episodes
where the beginning and end are the ways
to keep you hooked right we're like
everything else has been great but it
hasn't been as like a gripping and then
this one is like nah this isn't some
just like we got to end it on a
cliffhanger this whole thing was so good
yeah good interspersing like every 10 or
so minutes there's like a what what yeah
to keep you going for the night oh yeah
I mean even with the even with the
character growth though the lady with
the rats yeah actually that's the one
the one thing I really liked her
Jonathan and Nancy is the reaction to
the situation
of just alright let's grab some let's go
in because I've gone through so much
[ __ ] already that at this point even
though it's been a long time since
something happened they're just like
alright grab it let's go in they're
probably the few people who are going
like it's Hawkins we know something's
probably yeah I should go check yeah and
to that effect to about you know just
moving on and not retreading the season
I appreciated this scene where they go
back to the lab for that purpose
especially where you actually go back
and you're like it's it's the carcass of
the old lab clearly whatever is
happening is moved on from here you know
well the writing of Joyce in that moment
to because it was like the first episode
or something they were rejected out who
the hell still lives in Hawkins yeah you
know but to have even that debate with
Joyce brought up and apparently she
been trying to move out of Hawkins so
good on the show for knowing that you
wouldn't one of these people be trying
to leave but at this point you know
especially Joyce out of everyone for the
most part I feel like the writing really
does a just a great job of never losing
track of its characters or just the
history of the show thus far but yeah
throughout all the seasons I've seen up
until we've seen up until this point it
seems like every so often they will grab
something from season one or season two
and it all feels like one big lexicon
dry Riesling I feel like they took a lot
of complaints that people had about
season two which was dry and they're
just very slow at certain points and
they really improved because I was a
little disappointed with you two but I
feel like so far I'm super engaged a man
it's going on so far so alright guys
well on to Episode four now it's so nice
to be almost done with the show so for
before we do that of course got to do a
peach in the day shadow you if you've
been watching since the beginning put a
post on our patreon page for those with
the shadow rewards here at the first few
people that like or leave a comment
they'd be at a shout out in the video so
that when people who like that post was
a man named Jay T cjt he's his clever
guy have I told you about him beautiful
Japanese man from Hawaii he's always
like are you got tall guy glory oh yeah
he says and you know beans himself in a
bottle of sake yeah jumps into a giant
sushi roll he wears a red bandana
he does the hot Dukan over Google
Hangouts
he drives a Toyota and the super and
Nissan yeah what does that matter on the
set of jjt I see on patreon we have
messages I'll message people back and
forth all the time have a message him in
a while he's smart he hits me up on
Twitter to tell me about all these like
early screenings he gets access to he
doesn't have a YouTube channel
he doesn't do anything really movie
really
the internet somehow he gets into more
early skies how John I do one or the
other
you choose to get the exclusive ones
maybe or you could get all of them but
not be in the visible JT I feel like
every time we shout you out we always
try not to go stereotypical but this is
easily the most stereotypical we've got
and this is offensively services yeah
look out for Godzilla or as Gojira as
your family calls him
Oh mr. robot we haven't done that yet
yeah when ease it in Hawaii why I made a
Pearl Harbor - he's been pledged for
like a year he knows where it does
messing with - give it five more years
[Music]
take a stop a truck